oh my
God Emily oh my
God shut up no you have to shut your
mouth it needs to shut oh my God no no
oh I want to
[Music]
dance oh hold on hold on I have a call
hold on hometag
hello yeah okay
yeah did you yeah did you try restarting
it you did you restart it you you did
you you just did or you're you're about
to you did already okay did it what what
does it
say no okay okay sir sir okay sir it
sounds to me like you're having a
software problem okay and this is
hardware so I'm going sir I'm I'm going
to have to translate you please
hold I am back shut up oh my God you
need to shut it find it open it and then
shut it Emily oh my God it is shutting
oh my God you need to shut up oh my God
you shut and he danced I will dance I
can't dance but I'll dance you make me
want to dance I can't I'm it work I'm at
work I am at work and I cannot dance
right now okay but if I was at home I'd
be dancing because what because of what
you're saying you need to
show shut your mouth shut your mouth
Emily Emily
Emily Emily shut shut your you're not
listening oh my God oh my God oh God
Emily you need to shut up and you you
refuse
you consistently refus to shut up and
I my God
Emily oh god oh my
god thank you for calling homech this is
Hank how I help you
Hank
Henry regarding Henry Harrison Bor I'm
I'm sorry who is this it was your
roommate
bro uh I'm just going to see how your
first days go and just check in just
being a friend it's going it's going
well are you eating there a little sin
Toast Crunch you know I was looking at
the box and didn't there it seems to me
there there were like a three guys on
the box at a time there was like a a
skinny one a darkhaired one and and the
old one and now it's just the old one
who you know if I'm not mistaken I'm
pretty I'm like 100% sure his name is
Wendell and you know that's part of why
I'm calling cuz I'm freaking I don't
know why I know that
Wendall I forget family members names
and Wendall came right to me right
Wendell okay anyway don't forget I'm
checking you out clubbing tonight to
cele all right yeah all right I I I
won't forget oh yeah kind of sound upset
is was this sin Toast Crunch was was
this yours was it yours cinnamon
cinnamon cuz I do not remember you
unpacking a box of sin Toast Crunch
cinnamon what it's Cinnamon Toast Crunch
you know I bet wend killed those other
guys I have to go oh all right okay I'll
let you go where where you headed I I
have to eat and uh then I have to get a
physical company policy so you so you
going to go to like a like a regular
doctor or like is that let go I have to
go okay sir sir may I speak please I I
don't know why you are transferred back
to me this is a software problem and I
am only Hardware sir please
hold hello
Emily